yeah they're still putting it together I
I think they're doing a little bit
they've censored that the Chris Rock
special which I thought was really did
you see this I I didn't I saw clips of
it they censored it well apparently they
pulled out the Will Smith thing or
something wait what no that's the only
reason why anybody watched it I know
it's not true though didn't they do this
I saw it like clips of it from Netflix
I just read an article that said
something this morning uh that said that
they're gonna remove it maybe or
something I could be wrong I highly
doubt that no but I think it would Chris
not Netflix
you know what I'm saying look at let me
see let's see I you just have to cut
this out I doubt that Chris Rock removes
Will Smith joke from special
oh wow can they do that after the fact
on Netflix I mean sure they can do
whatever they want on Netflix but Chris
Rock's fumbled Will Smith choke removed
from Netflix special it's every article
I can read Chris Rock's Netflix show the
Will Smith joke will be removed LA Times
all this fumbled Will Smith joke
um if you watch the original he does
stumble he [__] up the joke if you
watch the original he
I don't know what he said he's he he uh
concussion when he gets to the word
concussion he like tells a piece of it
incorrectly and he talks about saying it
wrong he's like I [__] that up but
then he continues on
um but it's only one line it's a little
sliver yeah it's a little tiny sliver of
a thing that okay so because they're not
pulling out the no no no no no no no but
they're removing the piece which is
strange because it's like why'd you put
it in the first place you had Final Cut
you I watched mine a thousand times yeah
I watched it so many times you hate
every single SEC you hate the way your
stupid face looks you know you're like
look at my teeth you know like you start
to like pick yourself to shreds you're
like way to go you fat dad like
everything looks sad when you keep
watching it so I there's no way he
didn't see that a hundred times and
think about it which is weird that he
put it out because it's like well it was
live where did he film it at a comedy
store no no he filmed it at uh Baltimore
yeah Maryland yeah
um it's a weird idea though to because
he could have easily cut that out
yeah I mean like he could have easily it
was streamed live as it happened so it
would be an after the future there's
always a delay on those when they do
those those streams are never live left
you know what I mean okay never they
can't do that they know better right
yeah they're smart oh after all these
years of all that stuff that they're
like now they're like there's always a
delay so they could have pieced
something together I just think that
like
I think Chris as as
in my opinion the greatest comedic
writer of Our Generation he works man I
think he's I think he was still nervous
about saying that joke because it hurt
him so much I think that thing hurt him
so much you think it hurt his career no
no I think no I think it hurt him as a
as a human as a friend as a fan as a
homie because they have a relationship
and it's like
dude each year is one thing but hitting
me in the face in front of [__] 30
million people is like 30 million come
on
well I mean I don't even know how many
people saw that how many songs live I
don't know I'm saying live whatever it
is forget about live yeah but within the
next 48 hours but if you hit in the face
in front of in front a lot like that I
mean yeah that would that would do
something to you for the rest of time
it's the ultimate Heckle yeah 100 like
imagine somebody heckling you but then
like it's the biggest yeah yeah well on
the live stage it's the ultimate Heckle
it's like the it's like you can't get
more and well but also it's assault the
other day it's like don't you can't mean
the [__] face he should have kept his
wife's name out of his [__] mouth
[Music]
oh
uh so funny so weird so obviously
damaged to do that so scary and sad
ly shopping on Amazon I I do
and butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude